you mentioned you know michael malus he
just texted me asking
uh me to ask you
what do you like best about michael
malus if you can spend
5 to 10 to 20 to an hour talking about
the genius of michael malus what um
what do you like where does one even
start well obviously the haircut first
yeah he just gets sexier with age that's
for sure that's yes um do you you know
his ideas
his
trolling and humor
uh have you gotten a chance to interact
with him yes yes i've met michael maybe
10 12 years ago in new york i used to
live in new york when he used to live in
new york
i met him a couple of times there was an
um
a bunch of anarchists in new york used
to throw a happy hour uh once a month it
was called the high time preference
uh happy hour
in honor of hanzo manhatta so i met him
there a couple of times and
we followed each other on twitter for a
while
is it interesting that you're aware of
philosophical differences in your world
views
um no i think we pretty much see eye to
eye
um i think the difference is mainly that
he's uh
he spends a lot of time focusing on
american politics and american pop
culture which i don't pay much attention
to i guess so you look more
at the monetary system the economics of
it all and just the history and just
looking at zooming out
at the
big picture of it although recently he's
working on a book called the white pill
and he's been
every every time i see him i mean he's
in some dark aspect
of the 20th century he's just like i
just finished writing about holomore
as you might imagine he's not taking
much i believe of a monetary perspective
on things
his book his writing at least for for
time has a
kind of philosophical ideology
perspective that us as a side of the
monetary system
but you argue that those are actually
inextricably linked
but yeah and i don't think he would
disagree but it would uh but a book has
to be
you know can only be so long i suppose
you